I had dinner between the last video in
this one so I might have forgotten what
I just did I think I was about to if
what I see on my board makes sense I was
about to use the the the Taylor series
or in the specific example the Maclaurin
series approximation to figure out a
polynomial version a sum of polynomial
terms - to approximate e to the X and
remember the D let me write here what
the definition of of the of the
Maclaurin series was is that we said
that f of X f of X is equal to the sum
from N equals 0 to infinity of the nth
derivative of F evaluated at 0 and if
I've ever remembered to put it evaluated
zero last time I wrote this down times X
to the N over N factorial and hopefully
that makes sense to you
this might seem really confusing and and
strange but now that we're going to
apply it to e to the X it should maybe
be a little bit more concrete and I
think at the end of the last video I
said well if f of X is e to the X f of 0
is e to the 0 which is 1 and F prime of
X I mean that's that's any derivative of
e to the X is equal to e to the X right
so you take any derivative at 0 and it
equals 1 for e to the X for this
particular case of f of X and that's
really neat that means that the rate of
change of of you know Y with respect to
X is you know for every one you move in
X you move one and Y that's fine EDF at
e to the zero but that that also means
that the rate of change of the rate of
change is also 1 and the rate of change
of the rate of change of the rate of
change is also 1 so at at e to the 0 or
x equals 0 of e to the X the slope the
slope of the slope and the slope of the
slope of the slope of the slope they're
all 1 which to me tells me something is
mysterious is happening and it's another
reason why you should just sit and
ponder e but anyway back to what we were
trying to do so how would we do this how
would we write the approximation
well we could say that let me write the
approx I'll call that P of X is going to
be a polynomial it equals well in this
particular case what's what's the what's
the derivative of any derivative
evaluated at f of zero well that term is
one we wrote that down right here the
dirt F of zero is one the derivative the
first derivative at zero is 1 the second
derivative at zero is one right that's
what's special about e to the X so all
of these terms are going to equal one
right so this polynomial simplifies to
the sum from N equals 0 to infinity of X
to the N over N factorial that to me is
very neat remember this these are all 1
in every term so that's why I took it
out so what does that mean well that
tells us that e to the X can be
approximated and actually I don't prove
it here but it actually turns out that
when you take the infinite sum that the
Maclaurin series not only approximates e
to the X at x equals 0 when you take the
infinite series it actually equals e to
the X so when you when you take a
Maclaurin series at 0 and the resulting
function the resulting polynomial
actually converges and that's something
we'll we'll learn a little bit more
rigorously hopefully later and when we
start doing analysis but it will act it
could actually converge to the function
at all points and it actually is the
case with e to the X so we can actually
say that e to the X is equal I didn't
prove this but you can you could take
take my word for and you can even test
it out with some numbers it equals this
sum well what does this um well as X to
the 0 over 0 factorial
well that's so let me actually just
write X to the 0 over 0 factorial plus X
to the 1 over 1 factorial plus x squared
over 2 factorial and you keep going and
of course that's equal so e to the X is
equal to X to the 0 is 1 0 factorial I
said in the last video is 1 so it's 1
plus this is just X plus x squared over
2 factorial
plus X to the third over 3 factorial
plus X to the 4th over 4 factorial and
you just keep going on forever and
that's e to the X and to me that is
amazing because this this strange number
a this 2.7 you know whatever whatever
that we got from compound interest it
can be written as an infinite polynomial
this polynomial series or this Maclaurin
series that actually has it has a
certain Beauty to it right this number
is kind of ugly when you write it out
2.7 whatever whatever but when you write
it as an int when you write it to an
exponent power as an infinite Psalm it
kind of has a nice rhythm to it right
it's it's very patterned you would have
got guessed that you could have written
it in such a simple form and even more
what happens when X is equal to Z then X
is equal to 1 right so what's eetu the 1
well then we set X equal to 1 on both
sides and I think I have space to do it
here e to the 1 which is equal to e we
just set all the X's to 1 so we get
that's equal to 1 plus 1 plus 1 over 2
factorial plus 1 over 3 factorial plus 1
over 4 factorial plus 1 over 5 factorial
that to me once again is amazing that
the number E and we've just stumbled on
another definition of e e is equal to
the sum from N equals 0 to infinity of 1
over N factorial that is amazing so now
we have two definitions for e we have
this one that we stumbled on and of
course we had the ones from compound
interest that I will do in magenta the
limit as n approaches infinity of 1 plus
1 over N to the N that also is equal to
e this is starting to give me chills
because this very strange bizarre number
is popping out kind of this might not
seem so natural to you but it's it's
neat and it comes out in compound
interest and continuously compounding
interest but this is even simpler I just
keep picking one over the factorial of
number
and I add them all together and if I
take every number really in existence
and I sum them all up I get e that to me
is amazing one over n factorial of
essentially every integer from zero to
infinity if I sum them up I get the
number e you you hopefully are getting
chills right now well anyway let's do
the Maclaurin series for a couple more
functions and then we'll get to
something that is even more mind-blowing
I'll see you in the next video